aumenta la atención rusia dijo este
viernes que espera una respuesta
inmediata de parte de eeuu de la otan
sobre cómo evitaría una expansión de la
alianza atlántica aunque advirtieron que
pierden la paciencia virus fácil
al tiempo que hacemos un llamado a la
reducción de la atención cuando hacemos
un llamado al diálogo reafirmamos
nuestro compromiso de responder los
ataques a ucrania cualquier otra
agresión contra ucrania tendrá
consecuencias masivas y costos severos
en respuesta
rusia exige la renuncia de la otan a
todas las actividades militares en
europa del este y el cáucaso y asia
central a cambio del retiro de sus
100.000 efectivos desplegados cerca de
la frontera con ucrania pero las
contrapartes no parecen saber the same
time
escalation el golfo de huesos al tiempo
que hacemos un llamado a la reducción de
la atención cuando hacemos un llamado al
diálogo reafirmamos nuestro compromiso
de responder los ataques a ucrania
cualquier otra agresión contra ucrania
tendrá consecuencias masivas y costos
severos en respuestas el sevilla costing
response y esto incluye medidas
restrictivas que se adoptarán en
coordinación con nuestros socios
coordination y
este viernes ucrania despertó con un
ciber ataque contra varios organismos
estatales entre ellos el ministerio de
asuntos exteriores
parece un sabotaje en los tiempos de
inestabilidad entre ucrania y el vecino
del este esto puede ser un mensaje o
friday rangers el presidente ucraniano
propuso un encuentro con putin y bailén
para intentar resolver el conflicto que
surgió en 2014 con la anexión rusa de
crimea y que mantiene una guerra civil
entre las fuerzas ucranianas y
separatistas que han dejado más de
14.000 muertos